i don't know if this question applies to
you because i would imagine everyone
wants to get in the matt damon business
but if you could get the financing for
any project tomorrow
what would you make and why oh gosh i
don't know i don't i don't have
uh you know there's a few i've had in
the kind of the
in the wings but uh but i don't know i i
guess uh
i guess i'm waiting for the next one to
come my way okay
uh i really listen man you you are one
of my favorite actors and you are again
fantastic in this movie uh i am curious
though
uh did you love being the look of your
the way you look in the movie because i
would imagine it's so different than
what you typically look like
you probably could be anonymous a little
bit when you were on location
filming yeah if i walked around with no
problem
all over marseille that could also just
be a sign that people aren't going to my
movies anymore
but but uh but no i love that look it's
really specific it
you know i i could show you my phone man
i got pictures of these roughnecks down
in
oklahoma i could show you 20 guys who
who look like that and and it was a
really you know
specific and kind of i love the detail
of it and
uh you know the those guys were
incredibly helpful they
like our costume super supervisor was
talking directly to the roughnecks and
like everything i wear
is the stuff that they wear on on the
rigs and
the jeans with the fire retardant and
you know the whole
you know the the goatee and the and the
wrap around shades and
like everything is uh very specific and
and um and and uh and i love that level
of detail that
i feel like that's what makes it work
100
i love learning about the behind the
scenes the making of movies
um what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of
stillwater
that's a good question what would
surprise people about the making of
stillwater
i mean you know for me for building the
character i
that that that
that the real roughnecks were so
intricately involved in helping me with
the physical
physicalization of it that that i mean
that was definitely one thing i mean
the you know the i think for this movie
the kind of the
partnership of tom of like one of our
best american screenwriters and then
toman away two of the best french
screenwriters
making this movie that turns into kind
of something that looks
not like an american nor european movie
but kind of like both in
in some way i um but yeah uh
yeah i guess i mean i got about
600 stories for you but i can't think of
one that would be perfect
it's okay one of the things that i love
about tom's work is that the
dialogue doesn't feel like it's in a
hollywood movie you feel like you're in
the room with these people it's very
authentic
can you sort of talk about the dialogue
in tom's the way he does
his scripts yeah i mean and a lot of
that comes from
you know the his research and uh
i mean he's just got a great ear i mean
you look at all of his his
his movies the dialogue is great and the
acting is always great in his movies so
um you know he clearly has that that ear
but um but you know that's a specific
thing to specific characters and and
you know he having that ear also means
putting in a lot of work and
spending a lot a lot of time down in
oklahoma which he did and
um you know to get that to get that
cadence right
to get that vocabulary right uh it you
know
it's it's it's it's the product of a lot
of hours of uh
of uh you know it's it's a pretty time
intensive um
endeavor i love the way that tom shot
the oklahoma stuff
on static shots anamorphic lenses
and then you go to merce uh to france
and uh
it's handheld it's a completely
different feel can you
do you notice that could you talk about
the different looks of the
the film and you know do you notice when
that's going on with the camera
i mean you notice it's just because
because you see i see masa our
cinematographer who also operates
with a camera on his shoulder so i know
we're handheld um
but the the stead the feeling of it
right the slight difference in feeling
between if you're on sticks which is
just completely locked off
and if you're on a shoulder which means
the breath and the movement of the
of the of the operator is slightly
uh moving the camera is an effect that
you really feel as a viewer
so i know what he's doing and he and you
know and he explains that to me and then
i think when we return to oklahoma
he comes back with handheld as if bill's
brought something back from marseille
back to oklahoma so the two oklahomas
that book end the movie
are different um and that's all just
kind of
you know that's the kind of stuff that
we love to geek out about
i mean that's the stuff that i love to
talk about you know um but i might
we'll find out if the clyder readers uh
enjoy it uh you know enough when i run
the interview but before i run out of
time with you
i loved ed solomon's script for
uh no sudden move yeah uh just the way
that
and also soda birds work on it uh but
can you sort of talk about
um being a part of that see i try to do
every movement
movie that steven does i have to try to
play at least some part in it
um i think we're up to 10 now and uh
and he called me and uh while i was
doing the last duel and just said um
hey you know we you know he had another
actor for that part um
but because it the movie moved and it
pushed and because of covid and
everything
uh it opened up and and uh and i had
already read the script because i
usually read what he's working on just
out of interest
um and so i just jumped at the chance to
to
to you know parachute in and play that
guy plus it's a scene with two of my
favorite actors in the world don cheadle
and benicio del toro so
that was another easy yes yeah i got i
got to stop i'm just going to say i'm
looking forward to whatever you're doing
in the new horror movie
oh yeah well why don't you see it first
and then let me know
i'm confident i will have fun with it on
that note seriously congrats on this
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you for your time awesome thanks man
appreciate it